forbes has dropped its new list of the
world's highest-paid actors right now my
dream is all about deals and dollars in
a shock to absolutely no one
the rock is hollywood's contouring and
it just doesn't fall out of the sky you
got to work the box-office superstar
raked in eighty nine point four million
in the last 12 months thanks to a
reported fifteen percent take on the
earnings of his movies as well as his
700,000 per episode paycheck for ballers
rounding out the top three are a couple
of avengers chris hemsworth at seventy
six point four million and robert downey
jr. at sixty six million but there are
some surprises in the top ten so we're
handing out a couple of awards our
do-it-yourself award winner goes to
bradley cooper he didn't earn as much as
his avengers co-stars for playing rocket
racoon but in directing producing
writing and starring in a star's born he
got a healthy cut of the film's box
office success earning him fifty seven
million dollars and our other award the
prestigious way to go paul rudd award
goes to paul rudd that was crazy the guy
who doesn't age is a surprise inclusion
at number nine on the list with 41
million in earnings
thanks to endgame and ant-man and wasp
the tiny superhero earned a giant
paycheck way to go Paul Rudd
[Music]